hey everyone welcome to see each hat
hosted by cloud on air where we host
live webinars every Tuesday my name is
Stephanie Wong cloud customer engineer
and today we're back again with Ryan
Frizzle cloud customer engineer and
networking specialist so today we'll be
talking about networking 102 last time
we talked about networking 101
today's topic is cloud routing and BPC
peering just a quick note for everyone
there is a chance to ask live questions
on the cloud on-air platform we will
have Googlers answering them live on the
platform but we'll also save some time
at the end for any questions that you
might have outstanding so stop we're
going to do Ryan take it over thanks
Stephanie so stuff and you said last
time we covered VPC shared BBC and
interconnect today we're going to cover
routing in the GSP environment and VPC
peering so when we talk about routing
there's a whole bunch of ways that
routes get propagated within Google
cloud platform there is what we call
pre-programmed routes there's dynamic
routes and there are what we call
advanced routes so I'm going to go
through each of those so pre-programmed
routes are what we have when you set up
a V PC and you create subnets these are
routes that get programmed in to allow
VMs to talk to other VMs within the V PC
these are things that are automatically
created and these are also things that
you cannot delete or change so like I
said these are the routes that really
allow a VM within the V PC to talk to
other VMs within the V PC there's also
default routes that get created
so the standard default route that gets
created is going to point to an Internet
gateway and a common question that we
get is hey I have this default route
pointing to an Internet gateway can my
VMs talk to the internet so the answer
that is no not unless you put a public
IP address on that VM the difference
between the default routes and the
pre-programmed routes is default routes
can actually be changed so like I said
the default route that will be created
in your cloud environment actually
points an Internet gateway but let's say
for example you want the default route
to point back to your on-prem
environment unlike the pre-programmed
routes for VM to VM communication you
can actually go in and change the
default route
so big part of understanding dynamic
routing within the cloud environment is
actually understanding the cloud router
so a cloud router is a lot of ways very
similar to a traditional router that you
would have in your on-prem environment
but there are some fundamental
differences we want to make sure you
guys really understand so in a typical
data center environment your router is
going to be a big piece of sheet metal
has dual power supplies it performs two
real functions it provides control plane
functionality which is really the BGP
route communication mechanisms and also
provides data plane functionality that
is packets go into their cloud or into
the router the router will look up its
ribs and fibs and make routing decisions
and forward appropriately in the cloud
environment the cloud router is actually
only a control plane device right so
packets that go into your router on-prem
they actually don't go into the cloud
router in the in the GCP environment the
cloud router functions as a control
point only device and really it learns
routes from your on-prem router or from
other routers in the cloud environment
you can really think about it as a BGP
speaker right it only speaks BGP whereas
your routers that you may have on Prem
may speak other routing protocols this
only speaks BGP so I want to make sure
that we're clear on that front what it
does is it learns routes dynamically it
will configure routing tables but then
what it does is it actually pushes those
routing tables down to the v ends
themselves so you can think of every VM
in a cloud environment is really hosts
routing right as opposed to say a host
in your data center that when it needs
to route a packet it's going to push the
packet to the router the router is going
to look at ribs and fibs and make a
forwarding decision in this case the
router table actually lives on the VM
itself so when the VM needs to
communicate something be it another VM
or maybe your router that is on Prem
it's actually gonna route directly to
that IP address because it has that
routing table on the VM itself one of
the last things to understand about the
cloud router is it is a Google managed
process so while you control it and
configure it it's actually a process
that we run on Google hosts and the big
part to understand about this is if it
fails right for any reason Google will
Reese pin up that cloud router and and
re-establish the environment there's
nothing that you have to do in terms of
your piece of that as long as you've
configured it correctly in the event of
failure Google will take
bringing it back up so when you're
setting up the cloud router or when
you're saying POV PC really there's two
routing modes that you can enable so one
is what we call regional routing the
other is what we call global routing so
regional routing is where when you put a
cloud router in a particular region it
will only learn subnets in that region
so for example if I have an East a
central and a West region and I have
regional routing modes enabled the cloud
router if I put it in the west will only
learn the subnets that I put in the west
region and will only advertise those
subnets out to either a VPN that you've
connected it to or a dedicated
interconnect that you're connecting to
but it's only picking up those subnets
that you configured in the West Region
couple questions actually going back to
that sure the first question is do you I
know you talked about cloud routing
being kind of the the option for Google
cloud but do we support any kind of
other routes routers such as Cisco so
we're working on that the answer really
is we will support other cloud or
routers in the cloud environment but I'm
gonna tell you why I don't really think
it's a it's a good thing to do so
because our cloud router is heavily
integrated with our platform we're able
to take the data plane off there right
so if you were to go drop you know a
Cisco or juniper or there a sort of
cloud rather on the environment it's
really creating a single point of
failure right because it's operating
like a very traditional router so you're
creating a choke point because all the
packets have to flow through that router
because it operates very much like a
traditional router in your on-prem right
packet flows to the router the router
will look up you know make a routing
decision and forward things on now what
we're doing is we're working to figure
out how do we integrate that more with
the platform so that we can sort of
eliminate that and make the
functionality that are more usable for
customers and not have to create that
that choke point or a single point of
failure yeah because when that does fail
because it is a data plane device your
traffic dies with it right right but as
I talked about when the cloud router
fails because it's only a control plane
device the data plane can still function
as long as you have some other cab
that's which I'll talk about a little
bit okay great thank you
so let's talk about global routing so
we're talk about regional routing where
the router only picks up regional
subnets the other option to configure in
your vbc is global routing
and just to mention again you said this
at the VPC level but this is actually
how the cloud routers themselves will
operate within that VPC so global
routing really it allows their router to
pick up all subnets so back to my
example if you had in East a central and
a West region and you had subnets on all
of them remember when I said in the
regional mode if you put the cloud right
on the West it would only pick up the
west subnet but if you're in global mode
in the cloud riders in the West it'll
actually pick up the subnets in the West
the central and the East so this really
helps it's very powerful in terms of
when you're configuring DPC's we talked
about in the first session where you
have a global V PC construct and you
have a shared V PC construct and you
don't want to be putting cloud routers
in all of the regions all around the
world you can actually put cloud routers
in a couple regions enable global
routing and have it learning routes
throughout the entire V PC so it
simplifies your operational environment
now there are some caveats which I'll
talk about when you get to load
balancing which is in the future session
because load balancers tend to be
regional resources there are some very
specific use cases where you'd want to
use a regional routing versus global
routing because there are such thing as
regional constructs in kind of I know
you know might not well we'll save it
for the next one as well but any kind of
use cases for using one over the other
regional versus global
yeah it really comes down to the case
for load balancers right when you start
to inject internal load balancers in the
environment then you have to be careful
of using global routing because it's a
regional construct you could in essence
create black holes where you're trying
to route things from one region to the
other but because it's a regional
constantly lives in one region say you
put the load balancer on the central and
trying to push something from the west
it may actually not be able to reach it
because it's a regional construct okay
so there's something kind of have to
plan in advance yeah you have to sort of
understand what components of GCP you're
going to be using and that will sort of
influence of like what sort of Rowdy you
want to use whether it's regional or
global okay the other thing I'll talk
about is route priority here so for
those that are familiar with BGP route
priority is the equivalent to the BGP
metric med right just multi exit
discriminator so when you see route
priority in our console just think of
med that's how it will manifest itself
when you go into your routers on Prem
and you look at the route priorities so
the standard default route priority for
all routes
is a thousand so if you don't change
anything when you go into your router
and you look at the the med that your
router is seeing it will see all of your
subnets your advertising you'll see a
rout party of a thousand now that will
change if depending on the configuration
where your interconnects are versus
where your subnets are so for example
let's go back to the east-west central
sort of environment if I have a subnet
in the West and I'm advertising that
subnet through an interconnect in the
east what will actually happen is the
cloud router knows that that subnet
lives in the West Region but that
interconnect is in the East region so it
will artificially inflate that route
priority by some value which is based on
the RTT time from where the interconnect
was built to where the sub that is built
so for example if you were advertising
two subnets one out of the East one of
the West to an interconnect in the east
and you set the route pretty as a
thousand for both of them and then one
india router and looked at the metric
for med you would see that the subnet in
the east had a route party of a thousand
which is what you configured but you'd
see your subnet in the west maybe had a
route priority of seventeen hundred
right and you're sort of asking the wars
that are 17 or where's that are seven
hundred coming from it's coming from the
intelligence that the Google platform
has and knowing that that subnet is
actually in the West so for example if I
had an interconnect in the West as well
and it was advertising those same routes
I would see the exact opposite they're
out in the West when you looked at your
router which would have a med value of a
thousand on the route the East would be
seventeen hundred so you can use route
priority where this really comes into
play in terms of traffic engineering and
how you want things to flow in the
network so a best practice is to always
have multiple interconnects or multiple
ways to connect in your cloud
environment so say you have an
interconnect and a VPN you could
advertise all of your outs across the
interconnect and you could advertise all
of your routes across the VPN and the
way that you would make the VPN less
preferred from a routing standpoint is
we'd set the route priority higher right
so higher route priority or higher med
is always the least preferred right so
for example you could advertise the
default a thousand out of the
interconnect and then you could address
all the same routes let's say a two
thousand out of the VPN tunnel and that
that way when your router sees those two
connections it's always going to prefer
the interconnect but in the event in the
air connect fails it's automatically
enough they
over the VPN right so there's still a
way that that Google would know how to
reconciliate if you had something that
you know had the same priority correct
if you have something that has the same
priority like let's say you have two
interconnects and they're both
advertising the same priority what will
typically happen is you're gonna ecmp
traffic across both them so basically
your load balancing that traffic because
it sees two routes with the same exact
priority
there's no preference to one or the
other it's going to use both both paths
so in this case it could use an
interconnect and a VPN or multiple
inter-caste okay so yeah so why is this
stuff really important to grasp in terms
of the cloud router so I talked about
failure impact right so when a cloud
router fails like I said your data plane
can still function right you just lost
your control points the only thing is
that you can't update routes okay so but
you have to treat that a little bit
differently in terms of your your router
that's on Prem
so what you need to enable is what we
call graceful restart so graceful
restart in essence what it is is your
on-prem router when it sees the cloud
router fails and sees the BGP session
drop what it's not going to do is it's
not going to start stripping routes out
of the routing table right it's gonna
say hey I saw the cloud router fail I
saw my BGP session fail but I'm just
gonna sort of play it cool I'm not gonna
mess with any of the routing and what's
happening in the back side is like I
said this is a Google managed service so
while Google is spinning up that cloud
router you're still pushing packets
right because again it's a control plane
only device on our side so you can still
push data plane packets right and what
happens is after 60 seconds the cloud
rod is gonna come back up it's gonna
re-establish a bgp connectivity with
your router on prem and then
everything's gonna be fine again now the
flipside if you didn't have graceful
restart enabled as soon as the cloud
router failed you'd start tearing routes
down right even though that the the data
plane is still up and functioning they
would serve no no purpose to really
start tearing those routes down okay so
that's a key piece to really understand
the difference between like I talked
about you know me Cisco and juniper that
typical routers did you have on
parameters is how a cloud Robert works
yeah we're seeing a lot of the value-add
here the cloud routing the vs. kind of
the traditional set where that would be
more of a single point of failure yeah
and you know with the cloud routers we
recommend running multiple cloud routers
in the environment right you know our
typical practice is always run to right
if you're enabled with
mobile routing and let's say you have a
V PC let's go back to my es west-central
sort of example right
you could run one router on the last one
router in the East have global routing
enabled it's learning all the routes
maybe you have an interconnect in East
and West you're advertising all routes
across all interconnects that way if one
cloud router does fail you still have
connectivity to the other cloud router
now again we're gonna reboot the cloud
rather failed but having two means
you're always gonna have that BGP
connected ain't always gonna be able to
route so of course there's still best
practices that people should be
following setting up multiple cloud
routers you know everything that you
just talked about yeah typical best
practices are to use multiple cloud
routers use global routing unless you
have some complex scenarios with i/o
bees or various other things right
desert those are two sort of best
practices and then I'm on the on-premise
side that could talk about setup
graceful restarts just doing say best
best practice so that when the cloud
router fails you don't start ripping
there outside right the other thing to
understand is you know a cloud router if
you think about your routers that you
have on prep right it's a big box it's
designed with with you know very small
mean time between failure sort of
scenarios right they're designed never
to go down so we're taking all that
intelligence that you've put on a router
and we're putting on a very slim little
google managed host right so the you
know these are not these big robust
chassis that your router so it will fail
at a higher rate than say an on-prem
router now that shouldn't scare anybody
because I just talked about the router
can actually fail does not disrupt
traffic any way shape or form right but
you do have to understand that that the
construct is different so that's why you
have to sort of plan for these failures
and engineer for them so that when they
do happen it doesn't disrupt the actual
traffic right so I talked a little about
using multiple clog rods for high
availability we talked a little about
using route priority for traffic
engineering again this is where if you
have multiple interconnects
you can be using the route priority to
dictate flow so if I want to choose
interconnect a versus B a common
scenario customers may have is maybe I
have some very critical infrastructure
in the cloud I'm gonna build a VPN
tunnel but I'm only gonna advertise that
subnet
over that tunnel right so maybe I'm
advertising that subnet over the
interconnect with a whole bunch of other
subnets at a royal party of a thousand
and that's my normal path but I'm gonna
advertise just that subnet because it's
my critical subnet we have a lot of
critical infrastructure over a VPN
tunnel I'm going to do it with say a med
of 2000 so if I do fail my core critical
traffic will fail to the VPN right
everyone
Rebecca yep now you could advertise
everything over that VPN to but just
sort of depends how you're sort of
engineering hmm okay so let's talk about
advanced routes so advanced routes you
can really think of as static routes
what you're really doing is you're
configuring our Sdn control plane and
telling it how to route things right so
a typical use case for this is really if
you're trying to put say in that gateway
in place or say you're trying to run a
third-party firewall and you want to
force traffic to that so a good scenario
was I talked about earlier default
routes so maybe you don't want a default
route to Google's Internet gateway maybe
you want the default route to point to a
third party firewall you would use an
advanced route to do that you would
basically say I want for my default
route within this VPC the next hop to be
the IP address of the third party
firewall that I'm using so that's a very
common use case but you can sort of
control that and I'll take you through
some examples of how that's actually
used in practice when you're actually
configuring an advanced route there's
really a couple next hops that you can
specify one you can specify an Internet
gateway to a VM instance 3 an IP address
or 4 a VPN Tahoe
ok so I'll show you how to configure
advanced routing to a demo nothing so
let's talk about VPC peering VPC peering
is is one way which you can get to be
pcs to talk together the other way is
VPN which we talked about a little bit
in the in the first session that we did
so the difference with VPC peering is
it's binary right so where is when we
talk about VPN you can advertise certain
subnets so if I have a VPN between the
PC a and B I guess I only want some that
a to be advertised across that right
with V PC peering it's binary
so all subnets and V PCA will get
advertised to all subnets in V PCB so if
you recall I talked about pre-programmed
routes when we first started a
conversation basically what you're doing
is taking all those pre-programmed
routes in a and your program them into B
you're taking all the pre-programmed
routes and B and program into a that's
really what you're doing when you when
you do V PC peering another way to think
about is your sort of smashing 2v pcs
together to make one V PC now the one
fundamental difference is security
policies and I'll talk a bit more about
security and firewalls
in the neck
session but the key thing understand
about VPC peering is the security
policies are done at the VPC level so
even though you smash to V pcs together
and make sort of one logical V PC in
terms of the pre-configured routes you
still actually have two separate
security policies so I've had customers
call me and say hey I've done BBC
peering I've put these two V pcs
together but I can't actually see
trapper the traffic won't route back and
forth yeah it typically is because you
have two separate security policies and
the policies are written such that
you're not allowing traffic from the
other V PC so a lot of times if you do V
PC peering and things aren't aren't
working as you expect them to go and
check the the firewall policies and the
security policies that you applied in
both pcs this also makes me kind of
think about can you have overlapping IP
ranges or subnet IP ranges No so when
you peer to V pcs together you cannot
have overlapping I keys because it
wouldn't know how to route them it would
say hey when it has to make a routing
decision says hey I see this this IP
here and here I don't know what to do so
actually if you have two overlapping
subnets and you try to peer to V pcs it
actually does that check on the backside
and will tell you that you can't peer
those TV pcs together so this is
something that you're planning on using
you need to consider that right in terms
of your IP allocations and your subnet
setups so when you go to deploy will
actually kind of prep it for deploying
if it realizes that they're correct when
you so you'll build to be PC separately
and then you say I want to peer them and
you have to do peering on both sides
yeah so this could be used for example
to interconnect a DPC that you own with
the BBC maybe a customer organization
Owens right so what you don't want to do
is you don't wanna just be able to
enable V PC peering to another V PC
right it's sort of like a VPN
configuration in terms of you got to
configure the Gateway on one side and
the Gateway and the other yeah when you
do the EPC peering you have to configure
it on your side and you have to
configure it on the other side and both
sides have to be set up just a match
right and then it'll allow the appearing
to happen okay got it
so a few things to be cognizant about
right
there's quotas around this so a common
architecture might be a hub-and-spoke
sort of architecture so you have your
hub and you have maybe five spokes as
long as the total number of VMs in that
peering arrangement is not over 15,500
you're okay if you go to exceed 15,000
primaried it's not going to allow you to
set up that peering session the other
thing to understand is you can have 25
peered networks right so if we have a
hub-and-spoke
environment you can think of I've got
one hub I can have 24 spokes as long as
the total number of EMS are also under
fifteen thousand five hundred so one
last thing to understand there is the
transitive nature or non transit nature
really of peering so what I really mean
by that is if you have vp c a b bc b and
d bc c and a is period with b and b is
period with see a lot of customers last
can a get to see and the answer is no
because it's non-transitive in nature so
if you want a to get to see you'd have
to peer a and c but a cannot transit b
to get to see so that's another key
thing to sort of understand okay is
there kind of you kind of know the
philosophy behind why Google wanted to
design it that way
it's really just to facilitate you know
interacting with other V PCs and being
able to take all those pre-configured
routes and being able to push them other
places yeah right without having to use
a VPN tunnel like if you just want to
say I'm on all of the sudden that's here
to talk to all the sudden that's here
but I've built them into two separate V
pcs it allows you to have you know in
one way like I said merge them into one
V PC yet still maintain separate yeah
for that use case especially yeah yeah
so you may have a you know a security
policy or a V PC that is you know
sensitive information that you want
access but you want to have a very
specific security policy for it right
one example or like I said if you're
interfacing with a customer organization
so maybe you're a supplier and you have
a or you have a vendor that you interact
with right well you don't want you to
have one V PC but one company of the
other managing it right you want to have
your own security policy they won't have
their own security policy right right
okay so I'm going to take you through a
reference architecture now this sort of
shows how all this works together so
what I've created here is three V PC so
I have a standard V PC on the Left I
have a shared be PC in the top middle
and then I have another share of BBC in
the lower right and then I put subnets
in there that you can see so 10.1 is in
the standard V PC 10.0 is actually
coming from an on-prem environment 10.2
is on the shared V PC in the middle and
10.3 is in the shared V PC down the
lower right hand corner so now I want to
interconnect a bunch of this stuff
together right so the first thing I'm I
talk through is the standard V PC
connecting it to the on-prem environment
so in this case I'm putting two cloud
routers in place and I've built two
interconnects
you can see the dedicate interconnects
in the East and the central region so
what those cloud riders are going to do
is they're going to learn all the routes
that I have programmed in the standard
VPC and they're going to advertise them
via BGP to the on-prem environment and
that's going to allow the on from
environment to talk to the standard VPC
ok so that's the first thing I did the
second thing is I want to peer two of
these so if I take the shared VPC number
two I'm going to peer that with standard
V PC so that allows again standard V PC
and shared group C to communicate
together via that peering relationship
right so what what I have here is I have
this that if you look at the bottom it
says programmed routes so in standard V
PC I'm going to now have programmed
routes and again these are routes that I
talked about in the very first slide
that you can't change right because I
set this peering relationship up I'm
gonna have programmed routes for 10.3 in
that standard V PC right and in the
shared V PC I'm gonna have programmed
routes for 10.1 subnets right the 10.1
got one in the 10.12 subnet because
those were the subnets I created in a
standard BBC and again when you peer the
two together it's going to pre-program
all those subnets into each of them so
that's what that program route section
is so the shared V PC number one in this
case the padlocks represent a third
party firewall device so this is a
scenario maybe that's a finance chair VP
seriously when I want to limit
connectivity to it so what that device
is doing is it's actually sitting with
one NIC in standard V PC and one NIC in
the shared V PC ok so in the standard
BBC I have the IP of 10.1.1.1 that's the
Nick that's sitting in the standard V PC
and 10.2 dot 1.1 is the NIC that's
sitting in the shared V PC
ok so now I want to be able to route
traffic back and forth so I talked about
advanced routes so let's take the shared
V PC number one so in this case I want
to be able to route traffic from the
shared V PC number one back to the
standard V PC ok so in this case I'm
putting an advanced route in there for
10 0.1 which is really the subnet in the
data center right so I'm saying all of
that subnet
you're telling sure BBC it exists but it
exists somewhere else ok and the next
hop to get to it is the firewall right
so that's that 10.2
one so I'm telling it is 4:10 0.10 that
whole subnet if you need to get there
which is the on-prem environment go to
10.2 1.1 which is the which is the NIC
that sits in that V PC okay I'm also
doing the same thing on the other side
in the standard V PC I'm configuring
another advanced route and in this case
the cloud routers are picking up this
advanced router they're advertising it
to the on-prem so the on-prem knows I
can get to 10.2 subnets but when it
comes into the standard V PC it's gonna
say Oh 10.2 doesn't live in the standard
BBC it lives in the shared V PC and for
me to get to 10.2 I need to go to a next
top of 10.1.1.1 alright so this gets a
little complex but it shows you how you
can use V PC peering in terms of the
shared BBC at the bottom how you get
preprint pre-programmed routes and how
they propagate but also how you can like
inject a third-party firewall on the mix
and then configure advanced routes to
force things through the firewall where
you at any moment you're secure right so
just to reiterate again so G's GCP to
GCP peering would be using
pre-programmed routes the appearing for
different subnets meanwhile you would
use advanced routes to force traffic to
the next hop which might exist in
firewall there yeah it's usually a third
party device of some sort so it could be
a firewall could be in that gateway
you've configured but you want to force
traffic to a particular device right so
you're telling it another example might
be I could let's say that firewall is
the firewall that I'm used to connect to
the internet so I could build a default
route in shared V PC number one and say
for all zeros go to the interface 10.2
1.1 and that would push anything that's
not part of your ten dot private space
to the firewall the firewall would then
doon adding on it and be able to push it
externally out to understand is another
sort of common use case for this okay
like I said this does get a little
complex so it's it's a little bit deeper
of a topic to understand but just goes
to show that when you're routing in
cloud there are lots of ways to do this
yeah and if they're trying to map out
kind of what they're doing on premise
then the possibilities are still here in
the cloud you can actually kind of map
it exactly there's lots of ways to do
this like I said you could use VPN
tunnels versus VPN peering or versus V
PC peering
you know like we talked about peering is
going to be binary so it's an all
subnets the whole subnets versus if you
wanted one subnet - one subnet you'd use
like a VPN tunnel ticket right right so
again anything you can generally do an
on-prem you can find a way to do in the
cloud environment yes you have to
understand the complexities of routing
and how it works how runner works how
routes get picked up and casco they
differ as well yeah okay so I'm gonna
take you to a demo and sort of show you
how this stuff works in the portal so
what I've configured here is I've
configured a demo environment make it
look bigger so we can see it so in this
demo environment I've created two VP C's
cloud on-air 102 and cloud on-air 102
peering VPC so I'm going to show you how
the BBC peering routes sort of manifest
and then in the first sub or in the
first V PC I've created two subnets one
in US central one in US East and that's
10.1 and 10.2 in the peering VPC of
create a subnet 10.3 okay so that's our
standard set up now I'm gonna take you
through the route so you can actually
see how these routes manifest so when
you're looking at this in the Google
portal you can understand what you're
looking at so I'm going to go over here
and I'm gonna go down to routes so this
is the first page when you come into the
routes piece of things it's showing you
all of the routes here so you can see a
number of these default routes these are
the routes I was telling you that are
pre-programmed right so these first 1 2
3 4 5 we have five or six routes here
that are default routes you can't change
these right and then it's showing you
we've got some peering routes in here
and then I actually have a cloud router
created that is actually talking to a
router I've configured off off site from
this and I've set that router to
advertise some some subnets down here so
the first page it gives you the total
view of all of your routes which for
this simple environment is very easy to
look at but I've seen customers that
literally have 10 pages of this so it's
even more complex to look at so if you
want to look at what you're learning
from my dynamic perspective so you can
see these 192 dot 168 blocks when I
clicked in the dynamic tab this is
I'm learning from the cloud router so
again I configured a router outside of
the cloud environment and I told it to
advertise these routes and I didn't put
any med on there right so that's it's
set with a med of zero effectively and
that's why it's showing up as route
priority of zero on this side and then
the next hop IP address this is actually
the IP address of the off-site router
that I configured right so as I said
when you look at a VM level right you're
gonna see these routes get programmed in
there there's 192 dot 168 routes and if
they had to route they would build an IP
packet with the destination of 169 254
dot 49 50 and they would route directly
to that off Prem robber that I've
contained okay the other part is is if
you can click on peering this is going
to show you all of the routes you're
learning via VPC peering so again you
can look at all the routes in this first
tab but it's going to get very big and
very complex if you're building and use
a real environment so sometimes it's
easier to look at you know your default
routes here but again you can't change
those and then if you want to look at
the routes that you're learning you
click on the dynamic tab if you want to
look at your peering route you click on
the peering tab okay okay so that's how
all your routes show up in here so
create route this is basically the
advanced route function I was talking
about so if I click on that it's gonna
take me into the ability to create the
route so I'm gonna give their out a name
I'm gonna give it a tell what network I
want it to live in I'm gonna prescribe
an IP range for it set up a route
priority just like I do for all normal
routes and then as I was saying you can
basically point it to different things
right so this is what I'm saying like
you're gonna point to a firewall if
you're gonna point to a VPN tunnel or
you would select what you want to point
that route to okay right so that's how
you configure in here and then just
click create it'll create that route so
in that VPC that route will then live
and all the VMS will get programmed with
that route so like I said it could be a
default route it could be a lot of
different things yeah can you do all of
this in the cloud shell or you can it's
you know I could do this in cloud shell
but you wouldn't want to sit here watch
me type everything out sometimes it's
easier to do it in the console yeah
absolutely
so last thing I want to show how easy it
is to configure a cloud router because
they're very very simple people think of
configuring router they think of I'm
going to configure my Cisco or juniper
which can be a very complex thing to do
in this case it's actually very simple
so this is the cloud router I've
actually stood up as I said I have a
cloud rod in this environment I'm
learning routes from another router
that's configured so you can see I've
got an up bgp session right here but
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna create
another router so in this case let's
just give it a name just call it test
one I have to drop it in a particular V
PC I could drop it in a region as I said
you know if you're using regional or
global this could be important so I'm
gonna drop this in US central one and
then I have to tell it what a SN numbers
is representing so the cloud Runner I
configured in here before was 6500 one
so to be consistent I'm going to put the
same thing in here I'm gonna click
create and it's gonna go and it's gonna
create me a cloud router so this is this
is the clock yeah it's literally that
simple to create the actual cloud router
now I have to attach it to things right
so I have to attach it to a VPN or have
to attach it to an interconnect yeah
various other things so that would be
the next up here and then once you have
it attached then you're gonna bring BGP
up right so then you can start
advertising around so really there's
three steps there's clean creating cloud
router attaching it to something yeah on
over an interconnect and then
establishing your bgp connectivity and
then going back to the routes menu i
show you and verifying that your routes
are flowing okay so still you might have
some configuration that you need to do
back on your on-premise network you're
gonna have to configure your on-prem
router so like if you set this up to say
connect to a VPN tunnel net VPN tunnel
terminates on pram you're gonna have to
configure your cloud router you
configure their VPN gate or you can
figure your on-prem router and your VPN
gateway and your on-prem environment
just like you would in the cloud
environment once everything is
configured on both sides then you'll see
the bgp session come up like I have here
this green check is is what you're
looking for okay so that's it that's
that's pretty much a high-level overview
of sort of routing in GCP and VPC
peering so let's go take some questions
yeah we'll be back in just a minute with
some questions
you
all right thanks so much for all of your
questions here we have a handful go
ahead and read them out the first one is
is a cloud router operating and/or
configurable at layer 2 or 3 so the
cloud runner itself is a layer 3 device
it operates just like a traditional
router right depending on the
interconnect type so if you're using
like a dedicated interconnect or a
partner interconnect that's really a
layer to interconnect we are going to
configure the interconnect and then what
you can do is are going to build a VLAN
attachment so that's your layer 2
element and what you do is you attach
the VLAN off of the inter connect to the
cloud router right but they actually
will configuring in terms of the cloud
or it's actually operating only at a
layer 3 level it's really just an IP
routing device set it's it's really a
bgp speaker right really what it is ok
great so next question is can you apply
instance and route tags to route traffic
to specific instances so you can so
there's a concept of tags where you can
apply so say I create a route and I want
to route to only be applied to certain
VMs right when you create the route you
could say I only want this route to live
on certain VMs and you would do that by
specifying a tag right so you could say
I want this route so maybe it's a
default route you don't want to live
everywhere right or a some some other
specific route you would build that
route and you would say I want it to
live VMs that have the red tag and then
when you create VMs you create the VM
and you put the red tag on it
and then what will happen is it'll
import that route into that particular
VM so you could have routes that live on
some vm's and not others by using tags
ok so you can map using tags ok next
question is how do you ensure you can
maintain routing locality to keep the
next hop in the same region or zone so
routing locality it's sort of a complex
sort of piece of the puzzle right so
this is like where's your interconnect
versus where your subnets this gets into
the topic of like where do you put your
i/o bees and things like that right so
it's really about understanding where
you provision things and then setting up
the routes to route appropriately to
them right so for example if I have an
interconnect in the east right and I
only want the subnet to my East region
to flow to that interconnect right I
probably wouldn't use global routing
right I might just use regional routing
and only advertise the subnets in the
east to the interconnect in the east and
maybe I do the same thing in the West
right I have a cloud router in the West
and interconnect in the West and then I
only want those those routes to be
advertised through that interconnect
right so that way you're maintaining
locality where the interconnect is in
the same region where the sub that's our
versus if we're using global routing
like I explained before you could
actually advertise your East subnets to
the West right but they're gonna have an
inflated med right because of their
large GG distance so that we're going to
compute for you so there are ways to do
it a lot of times like I said the
biggest the biggest thing you have to be
concerned about here is when you start
to put il B's in the mix right because
then global routing can really bite you
you want to make sure you understand the
concept of locality so like where that
interconnects coming in the ILB has to
be in the same region if you have an eye
if you have an interconnect in the West
and an il be in the central region the
interconnect lives in the West and the
il be lives in the central region and
they can't talk to each other right so
if you have global routing and you're
advertising a subnet out of the central
through the interconnect in the West
it's actually I'm coming to West but it
can't actually hit the il be I think so
that's word sort of this gets load
balancers keeping it as a regional cloud
router and advertising the appropriate
yeah how you won't have sort of
advertise this up yes
okay great next question is our firewall
rules imported into a peer network so no
so when you do BBC peering as I
mentioned the firewall rules and the
policies are designed separately right
so BBC a has its own set of security
policies and rules BBC has its own
policies and rules right so if you for
let's say example I have 10.1 in BBC a
and 10.2 and BBC B right I may have
firewall rules that allow 10.22 talk to
a whole bunch of stuff right and I may
have firewall rules in BBC a that
lockdown 10.1 right those those rules
I've written do not go across with
peering right so you still have to
configure the security policies
independently right and you have to
enable that that peering flow
potentially depends it depends what your
policy really is if your policy lock
down really tight you could peer to
things and actually nothing could happen
if you have a very loose policy where
you're sort of letting any VM to talk to
any VM without you know say 10 dot
address yeah then chances are you're not
gonna have any issues okay it depends
actually the direct question know the
rules that you write in policy a when
you do peering do not go over to VP CB
okay got it
and the last one is Canon in
have more than one network interface
which each went within each interface
and different VPC networks
said that again yeah yeah so this was a
good example this was the third-party
firewall that I had configured in that
sort of a use case right
so that was an underlying VM running a
third-party firewall appliance on top of
it and it had one NIC sitting in the WPC
on the left and one NIC sitting in the
BPC on the right so you can absolutely
do that you can actually you actually
have eight next to play with okay now
one NIC can only sit in one V PC okay
right so if I have a VM and there's
eight NICs on it only one of those next
can live in BBC a one of those next
could live in BBC B and I can basically
connect it to eight different okay and
that's at the instance of those were
like one VM could have multiple Network
correct one VM is going to have eight
effective NICs on it yeah okay wow that
really expends the use case I think
there yep all right so I think that's
all the time we have thank you so much
everyone for joining us today please
stay tuned for the next session which is
how app maker can enhance the G suite
experience thank you so much Ryan next
time network 103
you